all right hi everyone joining the
live stream
we are looking at some remaining
features for version 13
and um this is hopefully going to be
just picking up some loose ends here
so please
graphics tour video is what we want to
hit today oh that's dedicated to that
really i i are we really going to get
this for this version
and we have jeremy i
i'm not sure but i think we want to uh
let's give it a try yeah
okay where do i where do i go to see it
uh pick the reference page graphics tour
video sources
why don't we put this in just as a
function repository thing
for now i just don't think it's going to
be cooked
but let's take a look
i don't think so either because i think
it requires actual uses before it i
agree so let's put it in the function
repository but let's spend some time
discussing i still want to get sort of
warmed up
jeremy is here
carlo is here let's spend a little bit
of time discussing what the issues are
what's good what's bad okay
okay
all right so let me play this one
not surprisingly decent
that is surprisingly decent i told you
you didn't want to play these yesterday
that's two points just one spot to
another
yes
but how does it get how does it know how
to get there
that says how to get where that's a
scale parameter you could give it actual
pixels i know but how does it move
around to those oh currently we just do
a linear um
trajectory
there is no language there's no language
to sort of control that right now
stephen
like how fast it moves and what curve it
follows and things like that yes so it's
just going to stress
yes
you can specify the speed by controlling
the times but yeah it's only strike
lines at the moment
so raster size is that your window kind
of preserve an aspect ratio or
no the width is specifying the window
how large or small you want to be is
controlled by the width and raster size
we just need one size throughout the
whole generated video and that's that
raster size so width of the path through
the image or what's the width it's not
width of a bounding box that we grab
from around that position okay it's the
viewport got it
well not viewport because it's the
entire
linear path
that contains the right all viewports
right now i understand but yeah at a
given point
the question is how big is the region of
interest so to speak in the yeah exactly
yeah it's sort of a strip that you
follow basically
this one is and then the one after it is
a fixed
position and you change the size you
change the zooming or that width
from 1500 pixels to 200 pixels
if you move outside of that animated
images event the button goes away
these are pretty nice this is
surprisingly compelling
yeah i haven't actually seen this myself
until now
yeah we put them together i think
tuesday with carlos
that's right
[Laughter]
yeah now it's absolutely key that we we
we produce a lot you know we use it a
lot so we kind of know what's essential
use use cases okay so i want to try
something which is i want to see how if
i have a graphics grid
how i can visit each one and then visit
zoom out visit zoom out
you get what i'm saying
i do a graphics grid is however not the
graphics but this graphics grid is a
graphics
you by the time that graphics are
produced we don't know anything that it
came from a graphics grid
okay
so i mean that's an example of something
okay so the use case that you have here
is livening up photographs basically
well really zooming into graphics was
one of the initial things we thought
about so the use case that you say
should be one of the easy things to
generate as well
well right but i mean it's basically a
grid tour
yep
kind of like a graphics grid tour if you
if you wanted it to make it sort of easy
symbolically specifying that
then one almost needs sort of a special
function like well i agree
graphics good to a video tails video is
a good model for that it's got like a
bezier curve exactly
you know exactly jeremy we um stephen
brought that up
when we started this actually yep you
know long you know a while ago so why
don't we just use that basically use
that algorithm
and make that a graphics grid to a
video
we could
that that would be a nice i mean we're
looking for more of these so i think
that that would be a nice thing for 13.1
we we have a whole
potential family of these
uh you know content generators basically
video generators
right well i mean so another one here
is
so these are pixel positions
and and this is a an image right so when
you say graphics to a it's actually an
image right
yes currently we support images and
graphics we were thinking of geographics
as the next meshes as well meshes oh yes
currently we do support meshes too
yeah geographics i started playing with
it but i need some expertise from the
geographics team because i'm kind of out
of my depth there
okay so here what happened to that tour
of italy uh carlo i think i think it's a
if you scroll down i want to get the
tour of sapinski land
okay
oh god i really wish people wouldn't do
this of defining a variable
how many times do we have to say the
same thing
so there it is used twice in that i
isn't used why is i used twice
if you scroll down don't call it i for
goodness sake
call it image or something sure
okay
that's awesome
i have to do yeah i have to do a lot of
documentation update with that
suggestion
so related to graphics are you changing
plot range
so things that had you know very small
resolution
would those come into focus
as you zoom in
for graphics yes yeah okay good um we
seem to have hung here i've got a
spinning disc there is
how old is your prototype bill
i thought that was fixed
carlo it should be
well i don't know i just launched it so
it is what
um
is this frozen now it looks like it is
frozen it might be i've had it last week
with something like a plot that has a
lot of wiggles in it do you need to do
something ahead of time so that that
so so
if the input is a vector thing um
no no
it doesn't know where the graphics came
from
yeah the graph graphics doesn't know it
came from you'd have to prepare it with
high resolution detail ahead of time and
hopefully hopefully plot will remember
where it came from eventually
just think in those cases you'd have to
reevaluate if you really want to zoom in
right
yes
right if it is if it is just a vector
plot
it will just change in the plot and you
will do the correct thing
but if it is something like mandelbrot
plot oh yeah i've got this one is from
yesterday so maybe it'll work better
i'm gonna this faces one looks very
interesting let me see how that works
but let's drive soon and get this one to
work
that looks better
wait a minute even this one
is this also hanging you think
yeah that is hunk
well
tough for me to really see much when
it's home
okay so what you're saying here in this
one
that's pretty cool if you can really do
that so you find faces find their
positions
and then where's the width
that's
automatically automatically in given the
position of the various faces
it's not about how can it be computed
automatically how does it know what the
zoom level should be well it looks at
the distance between the various things
and make sure that at those times that
the two windows do not overlap so window
at position one does not overlap when a
position two
it's not a particularly smart thing i'm
sure that could be improved but
right i mean are we good to not just
have a person's nose or something yes
yes
um
well this is dead again
very dead
these are both extremely dead
like
so dead we can't even you know they're
they're
yeah they're very very dead prototype
build
yeah
it's been a lot of development in these
past few days
i i wouldn't blame anyone for those not
working
branches are coming in and going out
at a very fast speed
well i'm sold on this function
to my surprise that the name of it i
agree we could discuss if you you called
it trajectory video um graphics tour
video is not as
general as it as it is
so i don't know if anything about a
video what about a tour video
or a
scanning video or
what are the names of some other ones
that we've got we've got snippets video
right
slideshow video
the only reason we had called it
graphics here because we think that we
need a 3d graphics tour yeah which is
going to be quite different in terms of
specs
i mean not super different but you you
have to sort of say where you're looking
where you're at and how you're looking
at it
so the question that i have here is
imagine that you have a giant
mathematical expression for example you
could do the same thing on that
kind of yeah
i think this is this area
of sort of
capturing
workflows
that are interesting that are useful
i think is wide open for creativity here
yeah
okay so
image to a video graphics tour video
through a video to a 3d video
what's another word for tour scan
um
i mean
it might not be a tour it might be
something i was just going to say
yeah i was just going to say that
you know
maybe that's a
sampling video that's not a very good
name either yeah um
sometimes you think of a tour as sort of
as a cycle you know coming back
yeah i know
it could be pain well it does come kind
of dramatic
like pan and zoom could be
could apply
unless there's more to it
no there's more to it because there's
also yeah
um
exploration video
voyage video
and and also it wouldn't hurt for us i
think that it it would be useful to keep
this experimental for one or two rounds
until we sort of get enough
um oh sure yeah confidence in him
you know
just related the tail that the graphics
grid like taiyo that'd be nice as a
theme for any sort of number of points
or if you could just apply the
whatever we're calling this tao theme
the the idea of going out to see the
hole before you zoom into the next yeah
kind of i agree with you i agree with
you
yeah i think that that's
yeah so you see where you're at then you
kind of indicate where you're going and
then you zoom in
as opposed to sort of you know
so wait a minute so what we've got here
is
um
well look here we've got path points
we've got
um
path type
that's some different you know the path
type would be a taiyo
you know like the ken burns we can have
the taiyo
[Music]
um
can you add rotation to that too it says
it all down here it says down here
rotate i didn't see it yeah okay
you got an interfact interactive
interface like the image interface we
have the
bar
would be nice here
we could just actually that would be a
really nice thing to be able to we could
we can pick points right in that
enterprise
and so could one automatically have
picked those points and have a video
produced
yes
wouldn't that be really nice even better
than point rectangles that you can
rotate right move and position
rectangles at different sizes and
rotations and it just kind of moves in
that order interesting yeah
more advanced jeff is suggesting
traversal tour
traversal video
it's not terrible traversal suggests
it's going only one way
um
path video i mean that kind of assumes
that
the problem with path video is one could
i mean is it going to have a continuous
path there's one question or is it going
to jump
you know boom boom boom boom different
places
and i think all are useful
to determine
yeah i think it can be themes basically
just what jeremy pointed out like zoom
out see the big picture zoom in again to
where you want to go next
um
sometimes that's useful
right
yeah and i mean the typical thing we're
doing here is
it
is
in a cycle i mean this this video is
going to be a um
a cyclic kind of thing so the examples
you have here
okay that last one for instance with
italy would have been a cyclic one that
traverses around the
border of italy
oh wow okay
many many points
we resample that see that array resample
to 50 so we pick 50 of those points but
it could be all of the points
this is an interesting very interesting
function
i i eat my words about this function
good great um
i think what we want to make it really
easy to do this kind of content
generation in the wolfram language
i think it promotes research education
and even corporate case you know if
you're going to make a
sure
right
but so
okay so what are we going to do for this
version
i think we need to be called
well if you want if you have a strong
opinion or name
we could figure that out well otherwise
figure it out let's figure it out i mean
we've got we've got name and we've got
um
um
path points path type
seem useful
or path theme
i think we could say uh both path type
and path theme or something
i i i'm i'm not sure we have enough
ideas to fill those up for this person
well we have a couple of path types we'd
say
linear
linear bezier
um
you know
our code phrase is coming up in a few
hours i know i know that i know that
that's why you know having this review
today isn't the optimal thing but that's
what we're doing okay path type linear
bezier you can handle those
um uh then
you know we've got path points we've got
um
i think we would say path times
i think a lot of these are going to be
sort of suggestions that the roll into
13 1 version of this all right okay okay
i mean
uh
do they all need to have the path prefix
given that they
if they all have it is it meaningful
anymore
i don't know
yeah but i think it's useful to know
what kind of parameters anyways we want
to be able to specify
and the other thing is um well unless we
call this graphics path video
i mean is it really i mean the path is
is that the main thing or is it where
you stop and actually linger is the main
thing
you know
no i think it's the fact that there's a
part there's something continuous going
on
well do you expect that the path is
going to have
you know 100 points in it or is it going
to be just like two points like go from
here to here
i think it could be either
we got examples with both
i mean italy has many points
and we could say graphic sampling video
i feel like that is the most obscure of
the other
of this collection i kind of agree
tour suggests that it's it's a that
you're seeing things that are useful
more so than path which um
and also i think that
path sort of focuses too much on the
path
um all right fine
what do you say a sightseeing
well it could be sightseeing video video
right but often they are called
often they are called tours right i know
i know i know i know
to a guide guys yes guide right
video no
um
do the functions uh
let me see do functions like find
shortest tour
is that um that's
that's not a cycle right or does my
choice to refine a cycle no fine shows
path it finds a path and tour finds a
cycle
but this generically it's not a terrible
thing to have the concept of cycle here
because this thing does
by default have a video that cycles
you see what i'm saying
sure yeah i mean i don't think that
that's probably the only function we
have right now that is touring its name
sponsors tour right
yeah
but that's a particular
this is very technical version of tour
the graph one
all right
i'm agreeing that graphics tour video is
probably okay it's probably as as
evocative as we're gonna get
and it allows us to have a graphics 3d
tour
it just bothers me that we've got images
and things in there as well
i was thinking dynamic graphics video or
something with dynamic but that's not
gonna solve the graphics problem in
there no
is there a problem with tour video
i don't really think so i think it's a
kind of a nice branded name i think
people will get used to that
i guess the only thing that we'll need
to make sure is that the specification
if we add support for 3d stuff will be
different but no no it's actually a 3d
video that will be to a 3d video it's
going to be different okay then
i don't really have any objection to
that or 2d
why say that
i think we just say to us a tour video
yeah yeah i think that's good
um okay so then
uh okay so what we've got
is
um
marco on our live streams pointing out
that apple maps google earth things like
that use tour to mean the same thing
i think
so that's a but of course that's more
geographic
rbs is talking about why this is called
parallax in early
video games
interesting
um
okay so
what what i mean
for some reason i really think path
points is going to be less obscure than
just seeing points here
and hopefully it'll have an auto
complete in things i think one question
about little um uh i was we are applying
to support both uh an association where
the values are lists but also a list of
associations
um and i'm not sure if the plural that
makes sense if
right because it could be
each association is the specification
for one point
well then then make it a different thing
i mean why not have
um okay
position
positions
position time i mean if it's going to be
in a list i mean doesn't it want to be
different it's going to be very
confusing otherwise yeah yeah i agree
yeah that can be done
um
okay so then how does time work
how do you specify it it's the time in
seconds presumably from the beginning of
the video correct
for each point so that's where the point
ends up on that time code yes correct
and and what about it like a pause if
you want that if you want it to linger
and then you might have to specify that
point
well it's a weird word for that but
why delay maybe
no i think linger is the right term okay
isn't that i mean i don't know is it
does it have a name in in movie making
definitely not linger
pause time i would have said if i wanted
to say anything yeah
maybe that's and we have the concept or
use pause in other functions too
i don't think pause pause suggest
nothing is happening during the pause
wait time or hold
time what is that there's a better word
for this hold
oh my gosh what is it there's a there's
a time there's a thing that means hold
on this point and then go on to another
one
still time static time
um
duration would that fit
yes it would in that particular case it
would fit just fine yeah um
uh
suspended okay so
i just wanted to point out that we only
have 17 minutes left until you have a
hard stop and we do have christopher and
charles here for the next discussion
right
well okay
i'm stephen
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
this for this we could say um
point durations or something
look get whatever you can in here is it
going to be adaptable
no no
that's a pity
is there thought to make this work with
animation or video
background image
being
a video to a video yeah so the way you
do it in a movie like a wide shot that
you could zoom in on and
pan across
by the way
you just convinced me that we should
make the name graphics tour video
because it's otherwise it's a video tour
video if you understand what i'm saying
yeah
but but i mean that could work in the
same function right i think so video and
video out and we still do this
the path specification might be
no no actually it'll work fine it'll
work fine it'll work fine just as a
different locations
in the videos
but that doesn't seem insane
yeah i think that's another argument
though to call it tour video because
otherwise you're gonna have to have
video tour video exactly
what sorry to call it to a video yeah
yes yes
all right fine
okay this is wonderful did you did
people who came late did you actually
see these videos
surprisingly compelling
yeah that's nice
and that's just specified with two
points
by the way in this case here it will be
path times and it would say
um
something about widths what will be the
right name for the width
point durations yes zoom level was
something that we had at the at the
beginning
i think width is better but i think you
you might also want to specify zoom
level yeah i mean
um
zoom levels that's one way to specify it
and the other way would be
um
it's not viewport what's the right term
what's what's the what's the image
processing term for a region
uh as a bounding box you're saying
yes look cause that's yeah
regions basically and that will be a
bounding box
path bounding boxes
returns is fine
well we got so many other things in
regions
zoom levels bounding boxes
you have to maintain an aspect ratio i
worry that is easy to mess up right if
you if it's open yep
there isn't a resize operation at the
end will do something
more or less
fix mistakes okay but it will probably
not look great if you okay so then let's
call it something widths but what kind
of widths what is it
um
view with maybe
well then this should be called
viewpoints
do we use that for graphics 3d camera
yeah
yeah that might be confusing
that's a very special camera
the one we use the most but it's still
very special
well what what do you think it should be
called then
it's okay i think at viewpoint it's not
too i mean it's just
different
if we go with lots of views
view times view widths
but yeah path type
that's okay it goes with path points
all right well maybe it's path points
maybe you can support both of them for
now
all right we are really running out of
time here so we better move on this is
wonderful
i'm sorry i attacked it earlier good
work
great feedback thank you
okay and um
uh you can get that file okay can we
move on to the next item where is the
next item
um in your calendar
and it should be updated
it's a single
function
can carla and i be excused yup go ahead
thank you go implement
thanks
you need me for this stephen
oh i don't know what it is let me just
find out find region transform no
no all right bye
okay
we got penguins
that's what you were trying to do
i think
yes
um
whatever uh
okay so the issue is we've got this
notion of geometric transform
find geometric transform and we've got
this idea of find region transform
which is similar but different and some
kind of inverse and some kind of
different return structure and so on
right so if you read slowly through
there and charles can talk to it we can
talk through every piece of in what are
they similar how they're different
are you roger are you at this point
convinced that this design is correct i
am
we absolutely need it for
okay but
that's different from saying the design
is correct you're saying
that the fact that it's needed doesn't
mean that these names are right so fine
how sure are you that the names are
right
somewhat okay
finds the affine transform that maps two
regions maps from one region to another
if they're related by an affine
transform this one finds it
why don't we call it our fine transform
no we want to expand it in the future
right now today
the two things when you when things are
congruent that's a special affine
transform when things are similar that's
another how
how findy is this and how much is it
deterministic
it it is deterministic
it is
multiple thing i mean if you give it a
repetition yeah if things are very
symmetric
if things are i mean the transform is
not unique right now
like like two discs okay
um
i'm sorry yeah you can
you can rotate the disk a lot and it
looks exactly the same
fancy that right
you know so there's an awful lot of
transforms to transform a disk to
another disk um
so
but it's not
find the in the sense of
um
local optimization
right
okay so listen if we had a word like
oh gosh what is the right word for it
what what is it describing is it
describing
it it literally finds the
the mapping or the transform between two
regions
so essentially find transformation
function find that transformation
function if it exists
yes
and sorry i think this was talked about
last time but does it only work if there
is basically an exact transform
yes it does enjoy fitting
but it has no tolerance option it never
will have or could it have a tolerance
option
um
will not um shouldn't
because really when you say tolerance
option actually is you want to actually
do a fitting which is what actually
geometric transform is doing
so you you know an approximate result
based on some
best fitting you have to define
andromeda some roughly using ransack
plus you know least square fitting plus
other different methods
well maybe a future thing would be that
fine geometric transform could work on
regions if it doesn't already but yeah
actually they did try for polygon but
then you start to see that there are
issue in the design because you don't
really get exactly what you want
because for polygon fine geometry
transfer for example doesn't take care
of um i mean
it's care about ordering
of point
right so if you deal with polygons right
you can flip the point clockwise or
counter clockwise and then you get a
different result
right well that's presumably kind of an
implementation thing right like i mean
if you give it a list of points you want
to respect the ordering but if you give
it for example a primitive point of blah
blah blah then i would expect it to not
care about the ordering and would
probably need a different implementation
but
yeah although i admit that is a bit of a
fine distinction
okay so hold on hold on the are you
saying find geometric transform should
work on regions
you are clearly not for 13. i mean
actually already in the system if you
look under documentation they actually
have example on polygon
right so they are going to extend it
one way john
right like i think
it works on it works on like old school
graphics primitives so wait a minute so
do both of these functions return a
transformation function but there's also
i mean this question which direction
should the transformation go
for images it's natural that it goes
backwards because
the way that the transformations are
documented for images are backwards to
more compared to anything else in the
system
it seems like the fundamental problem is
that fine geometric transform should
have image in its name and there should
be a different function that's what you
know
for other stuff yeah it should be kind
of an image fit or you know find it see
the analog you know if this is fine
region transform that should be sort of
find image transfer so maybe we should
change its name and gradually deprecate
find geometric transform
right
i thought about that but the only
problem is that i mean
like like we just discussed here find
geometry transform provide that fitting
functionality
some user may be used to right and find
image transform doesn't really
you know fit in that category if you see
what i mean
well it's really finding a geometric fit
it's finding yes
you could imagine making
if if that were phased out you could
have a function that's like an image has
the word image and maybe the word fit in
its name and then also another one that
has you know
graphics or region and fit in its name
right
okay so what would be the names we would
like to have if we didn't have the
existing names what were the names we'd
like
i think there's a proposal at the bottom
there i don't remember but um
stop at
that's a good name transformation
function fit
fit transformation function
yeah i guess that usually goes to the
end
of
transformation function
yeah that's a possibility
and i think i think the return should
not contain the goodness of fit as its
first level thing i think that's a
separate i think in most applications
you just want the best fit you can get
and then you go on from that i think if
we would have designed that function
today that would have been a property
that we could ask for
yeah and we could probably get like a
whole slew of other properties in fact
so i think transformation function fit
sorry
transformation i mean for functions like
you know the linear solve and stuff like
that i think that yeah we do it that way
where it's a property but what about for
like find fits don't all the like
optimization functions usually return
the error as the first
thing in the list no find fit does not
now the old the old
more sort of physics-y oriented things
like fit and fine fit they do none of
extra stuff you get no statistics you
know nothing about the quality of it
right you just get the fit
the which is what should do the
statistics one
gives you a whole potential you know
slew of of measures of the quality of it
and so does the machine learning ones
that gives you a whole slew of
of uh
basically
so geometric i mean i think it's useful
to say
is transformation function the right
thing it's a it's a rigid transformation
isn't it
um
no not necessarily widget
no can it depend on position
what do you mean what do you mean
well can can
this function
the thing is making a rigid transform
it's it's twisting it's shearing it's
doing whatever else that's a global
geometrical operation it's not something
which has a field where it depends on
you know where the the nose and this is
more for morphometric transformations
right the nose of the of the fish can
move
further than its tail and so on you get
what i'm saying that's a different thing
yeah like linear transformation in your
perspective transformation for example
well it's more than perspective it's a
field in general there's a vector field
that determines how much the thing moves
well it is it is transformation
functions i think i think transformation
functions just represent like half line
transforms right yeah linear fraction
so linear right so it's a very rigid
it's a rigid transformation no it's not
rigid it's absolutely not rigid it's got
yeah not shears yes very much not rigid
but it's rigid in the in the sort of um
in the in a totally in the non-technical
sense
right
it's global
yeah that it is
oh yeah not local absolutely yes and
that should be
you know that should be clarified in
documentation okay so look
geometric
okay what will we like to call these
let's say let's say the old one is
geometric transform fit and no longer
returns the error
bound
and then the new one is what
the proposed find region transform and
find image transform
what's what's find image transform
it would be
essentially find the matrix for some
number
you know
the documentation input will be on
images
it's also nice because it would go with
image transformation right because it
also they returned the backward one
you know the inverse one the inverse the
inverse plus one yeah so women find
image transform
and find region transform that's what
you're proposing
and right now and then we rename
find but we don't have to do that for
this version yet
we rename find geometric transform to
geometric transform fit
and remove its first argument i don't
think that's what charles proposed
what is charles proposing i think that
the find image transform would be what's
now find geometric no way
it's not on images it's on both
points
but we just adjust a little bit of
documentation i mean yes like you say is
on images so essentially geometric
transform fit and find image transform
with share both of the functionality
the only thing is that find image
transform will give the invest transform
where geometry transform will
essentially work on
what's geometric transform i'm sorry
how many functions do we have here
two or three how many functions are you
proposing
three
okay what are they
what are the functions you're proposing
so first find region transform where
essentially you take uh you know a
region one to the region two
and it finds the transform from region
one two and it returns a transformation
function
yes yes
and and this is this is an exact
transformation it's not a fit
exactly
and geometric transform fit does the
fitting
from region 1 to region 2.
okay
it also returns a transformation
function is that correct yes
so why is that one called geometric yeah
why is it called geometric region yeah
why not region why geometric we don't
call anything geometric
actually for me it was in geometric
transformation function or i mean yes we
can change it
so this is taking regions or this is
taking lists of points
by default is taking a list of points
but we can extend it to region
okay
and then
no wait wait wait this is not going to
work so find region transform
okay
again
let's see
so the main the distinction is just
whether it's exact or whether it's fit
yeah i mean i think this the fine thing
is more like salt whereas yeah fit is
more like
minimize
well why isn't this region transform fit
but except it isn't regions it's and
does this one do points as well
yes
well in the sense yes in a different way
i mean because it says the difficulty is
what fine geometric transform does with
points is kind of weird right where it
cares with the ordering
so i don't know if you'd want to if we
want to preserve that functionality into
region transformed
do it that makes no sense for regions
okay right so so do we have another
function that basically does that
behavior where you give it an ordered
list of points two ordered list of
points and it tries to find the
transformation
no
that's
no like least squares fit or something
like that
yes but i don't think it works the same
way
no for all the fitting functions the
order in which you give data doesn't
matter
it's a sum and sums or you know plus is
commutative how about that find
transformation function
then find these transforms
is that crazy
the all the things that generate
transformation functions end with
transform so far
like rotation transform gives the
transformation function
also i mean if are you talking about
merging all of these into this one big
function no it's all nice i'm talking
about i'm talking about geometric i'm
talking about purely fine geometric
transform becomes that function well
then definitely not because all these
functions return transformation
functions
okay right so
oh crap i gonna have to go i have i have
a i'm late for
well then then we gotta cover this at a
different time so it'll have to be later
today
bye
okay
okay so so this will have to come back
to this all right because i also have to
go it's going to be it's got to be i've
got stuff all afternoon and
you've got to pick a time because we're
trying to do this code freeze and if you
guys well let's talk about this for two
more minutes here
okay
um
so the claim is they all have to end in
transform
we need to rename this function because
we need to change its return structure
because we don't want that
well it's not just its return structure
it's also its argument structure i mean
that basically this function
this function really
it works for images and it works for
some geometric things but it has weird
behavior in the geometric things
and it returns a reverse transform
because that's what you're supposed to
do with images
well we we agree we'll have find image
transform anyway right
okay so we're only talking about the
geometric
parts of that function and also it would
return presumably a forward transform
both of these these go the same way
around the image and the region one go
the same way around or opposite ways
around
opposition opposite
so
we can sort talk about them as source
and destination is that right
is that the way is that what we're
talking about here
um yes i think it would be the opposite
right yes
oh boy maybe you guys can continue
talking about this for a few minutes i i
have to go um
where are we saving this
i actually don't know
this is geometry
okay
we are in the process of making a
mistake here
this is ridiculously confusing
that those arguments are opposite orders
i think that's kind of the fault of
the way that image transformation
functions work right now
i think this needs a more serious review
maybe you guys can continue talking
about it for a few minutes
um anybody else want to share the screen
or
um brady maybe you could pick this up
sure or alternatively
okay
or alternatively i i i unfortunately
have to go so
um
okay bye guys
bye
thanks